hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
whole organ mapping using ai and light
sheet microscopy
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by milten yi biotech
to learn more visit miltoniebiotech.com
let's get started before we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the ask
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker ali a turk
director of heimholt's institute for
tissue engineering and regenerative
medicine
in munich for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen ali you may
now begin your presentation
um
just checking
yes we can see your screen cool hi
everyone
it is my pleasure to be here today
sharing our recent research and
technologies that we have been
developing
and um and also
i would like to thank organizers and
military biotech
for for this event
since the beginning of human history
clear that we desire for a longer and
healthier life
even an eternal life which was actually
also the theme
of the gilgamesh epic which is the norm
for the first which is the first known
literacy of
human being however throughout
the human history thousands of years
the average lifespan actually
was far away from eternal life it was
about 40 years
however with the event of modern
medicine
we started to live longer and longer
average about 60
in mid 900s then nowadays
you know we live around 75 80 average
because we could tackle infectious
diseases
with the antibiotics and also could
tackle a lot of
injury related things accidents in
modern hospital settings
i call this area where we have been
increasing the human lifespan in the
last few hundreds
by your science either one or by a
current where we
are however you can see now
the curve is flattening because now we
cannot tackle
a lot of diseases that are related to
aging
from ischemic heart diseases stroke
neurodegeneration lung diseases cancer
and diabetics
so well it's also clear to us i guess as
a scientist
if we have enough time we will tackle
all of that all of these diseases one by
one
so we could already tackle almost tackle
a
big challenge like coronavirus in a
short time but we are also quite
optimistic we will be able to tackle
these complicated diseases
in some decades in some centuries i mean
if you say for example given three four
hundred years in three four hundred
years
potential of us would think we will be
able to solve all these diffusers
so then as a scientist and i asked
myself
what can we do to accelerate scientific
discoveries that we can achieve
the progress of 300 years in the next 20
to 30 years
so if we were to do that we would be
reaching to
biosciences era too so
call it bio future so that has been
actually primary vision
of my science since i started my lab
around
six years ago but how are we going to
reach there or are we gonna achieve this
increase again in the curve
well many intellectual
and scientific thinkers as well as the
authors from omados ul harari and don
braun in the book in origin
they suggest that we could achieve
acceleration in
technologies and science by merging
fields merging different technologies so
this actually has been also the core
of my research over the years
that we could put together
different sciences to achieve a
significant acceleration
sometimes 1000 times sometimes millions
times actually in data analysis with ai
as i'm going to mention
so today i would like to give you
examples of the imaging technologies
that we develop for
bio sciences combined with ai
technologies
and some of the engineering efforts
hopefully in a future talk i can give
talk
give you examples of our normal
technology related research
so now back to science as you know
we are an organism of interconnected
systems
from head to toe we are wired with
vessels
nerves bones other systems it's clearly
this is affecting one part of the body
will affect the rest however in the lab
we rarely
study diseases at whole body scale
so if you're interested in brain we take
out the brain make slices look at the
cells and plaques for example or if
you're interested in cancer in lung
again take off the lung and make
sections and look at the
cancer cells that means we are actually
ignoring
the rest of information throughout the
body
ideally we should be able to see the
whole uh scale of the disease and treat
the whole spectrum throughout the body
so what are the tools actually can do
whole body scale studies if you focus on
imaging tools
we have on the one side mri of mri
detail like immediate modalities where
we can see growth anatomy
over time but it's not informative at
cell level if you want to see
cells and molecules we can do tissue
sections histology or cereb
however this is very time consuming in
their heart to scale it to a whole organ
and almost impossible for a whole
organism like almost body
so the technologies that we
have in developing which i would like to
focus today
so-called optical tissue cleaning
technologies
combines these two arms so we can study
whole anatomy at subcellular level in a
constant time efficient way
so what is tissue clearing
as you know standard histology relies on
sections
and labeling the sections and looking at
under the microscope
which has been good for
most of the time however if you want to
study complicated structures
of vessels nerves and diseases extending
from organs
organs this is not sufficient
to overcome this problem we and others
have been developing
optical clearing technologies where we
convert
opec biological tissue in transparent
structure
so you can think of converting milk into
water now we can
see through and scan through to obtain
3d information of intact biological
specimens really at the cellular level
so when i started my lab we
decided to focus on whole mouse bodies
as the primary animal model used in the
labs
that we could study diseases at whole
body scale
in 2016 we published new disco
technology where we could
make the whole mouse body transparent
with
organic solvents for the first time but
also we could
achieve imaging a mouse body feeder
fluorescent microscope at that time for
the first time
then in three years we published we
disco technology where we could
enhance the signal of the
tissue of interest about 100 times so it
becomes more visible in this tier
picture
actually the same transgenic animal type
1 gfpm a subset of neurons expressing
gfp for labeling nervous system
you can see on the left in the green
picture we don't see much of a
nervous system very little because a lot
of autofluorescence from backgrounds or
muscles
even hard to see through bones and skin
on the right hand side after
increasing the signal in the nerves
about 100 times we can see
we will signal in coming from neurons
throughout the bones and skin very
very clear so we discovered technology
truly renders almost transparent like a
glass
if you put in the solution actually you
don't see it anymore
here for example it's in the solution in
the microscope
after placing uh clear transparent
models
to lighten microscopes here we have used
ultra microscope 2 which we kind of a
bit modified the
chamber sample holder that we could
mount the mouse
after mounting with the laser scanning
end to end we could visualize specific
labels cells so as a neuroscientist
i was very interested in first looking
at the nervous system of an impact adult
mouse
so here you can see taiwan gfbm mouse
the green signal shows the nerves
red shows the muscles
and white bones and orcs now if i remove
the
muscles you see the nerves through the
bones if i remove the bones and organs
you see
in that nervous system of an adult mouse
so let's
look at this now in a 3d we do again
remove the muscles let me remove the
organs and bones you see the nerves
for example you can focus any nerve from
tall
a single axon how it's going up towards
the muscles and forming neuromuscular
junctions
external bundles coming together going
upwards
to the spinal cord lower level of spinal
cord
you can see sensory and motor ganglia
and a lot of nerve innervations
throughout the chest
and internal organs and you see enormous
uh branching of the actions through the
four limbs
here through the toes and the muscles
so using this technology now on impact
mouse more than 10 centimeters
we could get the detailed information of
neural connectivity
so now we want to apply
this of course in that this is saying
that we
could see something that we could not
see
for that we did a traumatic brain injury
uh on the right some of the sensory
cortex of the mouse
so let me show it here
we endured an injury induced an injury
and then instead of looking at early
brain
as another lab would do we also look at
the whole body
looking at the whole body we we could we
were able to see for example
and changes not in the brain but
throughout the body now please focus
the nerves in narrating shoulder muscles
here
so i will show you the brain injury
versus
control case you can see in the brain
injury case
axonal connectivity is significantly
reduced compared to controls
so we are away from the brain we are
looking at the nervous system in the
periphery
and clearly it is affected with the
brain injury
so i guess the simple experiments
already showed that if you want to
treat diseases by even local brain
injury we need to think about whole body
not only just delivering drugs into the
brain
which we always try to do but maybe a
lot of problems could be already solved
throughout the body
periphery where cause additional
complications to the patient when we
started
imaging most bodies with we disco
technology we were also very interested
in
lymphatic connections which was um
about five years ago rediscovered by
jonathan kidnaps
carrie alitola and michael [ __ ]
you could see in this isolated car
perhaps some of the
meningeal vessels in green so we said
well to be able to study these
connections
by between skull and the brain
we don't need to remove if we were to
use we disco technology
to bring from scalp or we could do it in
type setting
you can see now the same uh prox1 egfp
mouse where the
clearly sagittal sinus the signal and
the other connected
branches of lymphatic vessels not only
lymphatic vessels but we could also
see the
immune cells inside here labeled by
double transgenic
six ccl1 and ccr2 so you can
see this um individual
microphages and neutrophils in this
lymphatic vessels in the sagittal sinus
through our region
so when we have been studying this
anatomical structures in the head of the
mouse
we observed actually that there are
some uh connections from skull neural
to the meningeal surface of the brain so
you can see here this yellow dash
so these are actually some small
vascular channels which rename them as
common angular connections
and you can see actually this is the
transgenic amount labeling nurture
fields
of course in the bone marrow there are
thousands of them
but also some throughout these channels
and the meningeal vessels
so not only in the moss but also we
could observe the same structure here
structures in the human cow samples
isolated with
meninges you can see again
from skull marrow from right side to the
left
connection and the immune cells
iba one labeled microbial and
macrophages macrophages in this case
so we using this
technology now we could dissect out some
previously unknown vascular connections
connecting the scar marrow to the brain
surface
called meningeal connections which we
believe now could be leveraged
to treat and diagnose brain diseases
from a new perspective
which we are now investigating an ert
funded project
when we apply these technologies in the
whole mouse body
in the most brains and heads of course
fluorescent microscopy micrometers level
sections
means thousands even tens and hundred
thousands of sections
it is terabytes tens of hundreds of
terabytes of data
one cannot analyze this just by simply
sitting in front of the computer by
clicking or immediately
therefore we had to find much better
ways to analyze therefore we focus on
machine learning
because um with the
rise of now deep learning clearly there
have been
quite advances they are proved to be now
quite unbiased compared to human they
have high performance
um accuracy could even exceed human
judgment and they can be really fast for
example
years of work could be done by whom
could be completed now with deep
learning algorithms
within seconds or minutes i will give
you three examples of such algorithms
with the all up versus vesa for vascular
segmentation second step mac for cancer
metastasis and drug targeting and
channel
technology for mapping intake human
organs here
for brain nerve counting
so clearly vessels especially in the
brain
they are very important and their
morphology
clearly shows any pathology if there's a
tumor
it sees alzheimer's plaque you will see
immediately changes in vascular
connectivity so therefore we think
we thought mapping out the vessels
down to microcapillary level in whole
mouse brains would be a good
way to study diseases so mike
and science biology scientists together
with johannes computer scientists
started working on the problem mark
developed
a day to label both large vessels and
small vessels
implemented clearing and imaging and
johannes implemented the deep learning
algorithms
which is called that and you can find
these algorithms
easily available on the paper link
so this is the segmentation
of the whatsapp of the mouseprint you
can see the
large vessels in cerebellum in cortex
throughout the mouse brain but also tiny
capillaries
in the brain structures all the networks
are now visible
after scanning we calculate all the
parameters related to
morphology diameter length and so on and
by merging to lm brain atlas we then get
vascular
maps of each brain regions more than
two 1200 in lm brainerd for
us another clear exciting implementation
of the
clearing technologies was in cancer
metastasis
you might know that majority of the
patients
actually die from the metastasis not
from primary tumor how that happens
hundreds and thousands of tiny cells
getting from primary tumor they getting
the lymph vessels of blood vessels
they are mostly eliminated by immune
cells
but some could escape this immune
surveillance
exit the blood vessels and find some
niches and hide their
their resistant immune cells and if the
treatment they're resistant and then
they form much
tumor and then they cause the death
in of the patient therefore
actually it is very critical for us to
be able to see this tiny micro
metastasis
in animal models where we study them and
then to make sure
if there's a drug treatment all these
tiny metastases they are treated they're
targeted
however there have been no technology
you can see this tiny fuel cell
cancer metastasis or even the drug
targeting for example if you think about
immediate modalities bioluminescence
mri computer tomography all
will give you similar images to be able
to see something you have to have
thousands of cells together nowhere
closely seeing fuel cells cancer cells
can
cancer stem cells maybe so with that we
could
overcome this problem together with
reiner zeitler beyond manza we
start working on the problem there we
transplanted
uh human memory carcinoma cells after
eight to ten weeks we
make the animals transparent using
vegetable enemies and cherry expressing
cancer cells
along with and therapeutic antibody
6810 which is conjugated with another
pluriphore
and disturbing antibody we know that is
significantly targeting these tumors
already
we wanted to now visualize all these
things at the cellular level
throughout the mouse body imaging
and
analyzing the whole data with deep
learning which is now called
we call it deep mag show that every tiny
micro metastasis and treated in the
mouth body
you see magenta here but also
quantifications
related to their styles and
distributions
for example in this mosque in the upper
graph you can see there's about 100
single cell cancer cells about 120
doubles
can cells together and so forth we could
really identify all these topics of
cancer metastasis
then we look at the data we observed
about
60 percent of the metastases
they were smaller than 75 size
very very small iphone 75 south is the
best of any other technology can do
so even then you can see about
two thirds of uh cancer metastasis
cannot be observed in animal models
that is actually quite a drastic loose
if you
want to study cancer metastasis and
understand the pathology in the word
drugs
basically so far it has been done in a
blind
way we can see that in addition to
cancer metastasis we could also
see antibody targeting you can see here
in cm in the middle
part which sometimes fully targets the
cancer sometimes partially
and there was for us important to
visualize
now let me show you standard imaging by
luminescence
where the mouse was treated with the
antibody
and in the red rectangle their lungs are
you see that the antibody this antibody
actually stops the metastasis
that's major purpose of this antibody
and then this method its cancer
line usually metastases to the lungs and
you can see that this antibody
in a standard imaging is working well
now potentially even people can think
it's ready to push the clinical trials
however if we do now uh high resolution
vdisco imaging you can see in the same
mouse there are hundreds of tiny micro
metastases
which were visible to standard
technologies
let's look at this in 3d video you can
see the primary tumor close to the leg
the big one
but also hundreds of tiny micro
metastases
throughout the mouse body in the muscles
in the bones
some indicate some in the lungs and a
lot actually in the lungs you can see
down through really
single cell throughout the bronchia and
clusters of this tumor cells
not only this metastasis but also we
could see the antibody targeting as i
mentioned
now you will see if the tumors are there
targeted they are
in white and the ones that are not
targeted by
the therapeutic antibody are using this
work they're in magenta you can see even
an antibody based
treatment could actually miss
significant
amount of tiny macro metastasis which we
calculated about
20-25 so imagine then
um if by just looking at the large
tumors where they're targeted if
a company an institution make a decision
this drug is working and they should try
them
in clinic actually they would be quite
mistaken but only after seeing such a
high resolution
view they would understand this drug
present but is not ready
not only that but then they there's
chance to go back
and bring a second antibody or or the
third one
to cover all the small metastasis
to make sure now we are ready at the
curriculum stage
at our best we can move to the human
trials
i believe just implementing this
technology in that way can increase
double triple the success rate for
oncology in clinical trials which is
about five percent now
so far i show you um results from
mouse bodies animal models but
can we apply this to human organs we
want to do it we tried all the
work that we developed for mass they
didn't work well for human tissue
there was a problem and the chemist sean
in the lab sold this problem
problem was um to standard on that
hydrogen that's this tritone that we use
for labeling clearing they weren't
really permeabilizing stiff human tissue
you can see that
they have large miscellaneous and they
got stuck
on the surface of the human tissue then
we made the screen and identified shafts
a new detergent with small necessities
and it could very nicely permeabilize
stiff alt human tissue
make holes channels and labeling and
clearing solutions could get in
using this technology we made whole
humanoid transparent and look at some
dye labeling
autofluorescence using magic microscopy
you can see the
iris and retina but also the axons
through
behind the eye and the immune cells
around
another need to die was we could do
antibody labeling in one
more than one centimeter thick human
brain tissue here you can see for
example ibm one microbially labeled
common brain tissue you can see white
matter
gray measure white matter gray matter
again a lot of microglia in the gray
matter
not only microglia but also the cell
bodies but their processes
they could be identified um after this
large tissue immunolably clearing and
imaging
and we are looking here really hundreds
of millions of
cells to just even
segment them cell bodies and quantifies
across the impossible task
again using standard tools from imitate
fiji
or in marius whatever you're using
they're all based on
glitters we could
do deep learning based analysis
now and that
grammy develop where we could really
segment
and count hundreds of millions of cells
that are labeled in large human
brain tissues now we can really decipher
architectural map of intact
livestream brain segments
so not only
um the
mapping of the human brain we have been
other we have been interested in
other applications so what are those so
we have been
very interested in using these
technologies
for human organ clearing to
map all kinds of human organs
that we can look at the biology in the
unbiased way in health and disease for
example here we made
and kidney from 93 years old person
transparent and then
90 a kidney from 93 years old person
transparent
you can see it's fully transparent matte
behind it visible and then we wanted the
image here there was also vessel
labeling and cell body labeling
and with standard um microscopies at
that time
that is now about one half years ago
maybe
we could not image this um
such a large tissue even the available
micro slight microscopes then we start
working with
um norwegian at that time militantly now
together to develop a new microscope
that we can
image large human organs which
actually then turn out to be a new
microscope for them that is called
ultramicroscope blaze
so there we outlined the needs that we
want to have
a microscope that can handle live
samples that can large samples you can
see here the
really big sample holder we could move
it um
several centimeters on on why they
mentioned
several centimeters on x and that so it
was
that it enabled us to image this more
than 10 centimeters
length and four five centimeters thick
human kidney tissue
and here is the 3d visualization of this
human kidney you can see
green enabling of the capillaries
magenta labels the large ducts and
cn labels autofluorescence and mid-sized
vessels
and you can see that on the left a very
nice labeling of the
capillaries on the right hand side so
it seems that they're not there and when
we look at the
killer malai in magenta channel we also
see
on the right hand side they're not there
mostly on the left side there there
so this already tells us that um
you know looking at this shows us a very
different
pathology actually which i was talking
to kidney express no one could explain
to us what we are really seeing
because in a way no one has seen such a
data
so we really start to think about
seizures in a different way as you can
see when we have a complete information
now we are also studying of course
different
uh have more healthy kidney and and
different diseases using the safety
technology
so i briefly mentioned that we are also
very interested in mapping the human
brain which is one of the flagship
projects of all biosciences
you know billions of investments in the
u.s
more than 12 years brain projects
started
there's no single map of a human brain
yet
i think a clear problem this organ is so
large it's impossible to cellular
details
to have using current technologies
so but now using channel technology you
could also convert
whole human brain into transparent
structure where you can see if condensed
light is going end-to-end
now we have optical access to
the human brain that we can get the
solar information
yet we don't have a microscope that is
even beyond place
um clearly we need here a new microscope
if anyone interested in working on such
a project
we would be happy to hear so um
but we are already conceptually working
on this solving this problem how we can
uh image uh how we can design what kind
of light should microscopy design needed
for
like such a large sample
and finally we are very interested in
using this
organ clearing imaging as a map
to generate new human organs
using 3d bioprinting technologies so
what is the connection you may ask
you know that 3d printers are 3d
replicators
that means you have to provide a 3d map
at high resolution that it will be
replicated by the machine if you are
talking about
human organs and their their bioprinting
we need then highest resolution map
possible that we can replicate the
original structure
for us it will know it will not use
if we just randomly print the issue or
if you
just put an additional sensors and they
go and become random structures
they will have very limited use compared
to real organization
so using shaman technology we could make
it transparent
and label specific structures and
potentially now
we could scale it down and generate
printed organoids
and also in the near future hopefully
the whole scale of human organ
so i would like to and by a small
summary um we are very patient about
accelerating biomedical discoveries to
tackle devastating diseases
to move to biofuture to this end we
use unbiased technologies
instead of working on proteins one by
one
we use a top-down approach and see
all for example proteome and
transcriptome and then go from there all
structures
but this is i guess the the best way
not to lose a lot of time we are also
very interested in
scaling both uh both data acceleration
and analysis
in the order of thousands even millions
at times
to this end we utilize whole tissue
imaging as i show you how muscle human
organ
and clearly ai is another accelerator
and we are using now all these
technologies to generate
engineered tissues that we can model
human diseases
for finally i'm very excited about
personalized medicine
because it's clear that all diseases are
actually
different first from person to person
even the cancer cells
different in the same person clearly we
have to solve
most of the diseases by at the
individual level
previously we couldn't do that because
we didn't have
the tools let's say the scalable tools
we already the whole cancer
let the line cancer the whole concept
already takes
several decades to study
for general top as a general topic in
thinking studying
them on personal person you need tools
that you can really do
research very quickly so i guess now we
are coming to this point with
such clearing and ai-based analyzes
technologies
and we have been working on this
concept by emerging technologies of
different fields as i mentioned
from engineering to ai to biosciences
with that i want to move to the last
animation which makes me
happy it's beautiful to look at i
believe it's taiwan gfp a mouse brain
where you can see this connectivity in
in mouse reading after we discover
technology
the cortical neurons but not in the cell
bodies and dendrites but their
connections their spacing is like
moving in a jungle you see every tree
every branch every leaf
you have really good idea about what's
going on in this
forest and you can see the tiny
connections axons coming out
how they go through the corpus callosum
to the other side of the brain
to deeper brain regions and we have all
this
detailed information throughout the
whole uh
mouse brain so we are really a complete
at least for this transcending animal
we are very close to having a complete
normal connectivity map
at the axon dendrite even maybe
of decent spine level
with that i would like to acknowledge um
the farming agencies of my research most
of those research has been done at the
element
i still have where i still have a lab
but in the last year we moved to almost
now um bigger
part of the lab focusing on engineering
of
tissues and of course i'm very glad to
work with an amazing team of multi
nations and multi-disciplines
we are about 16 countries now in 24
people here engineers computer
scientists chemists physicists
biologists auction expertise tackling
the questions together
with that i would like to end and i'm
happy to take your questions
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
now let's get started our first question
is
uh it says where are you able to
implement staining with b disco
i don't know if it means were you able
or where are you able
so important point and
we were able to
implement staining in the whole mouse
bodies
using um normal bodies regular
antibodies doesn't work because they're
very large i mean they partially work
but they don't go into deep tissues such
as
spinal cord brain tissue mostly
unlabeled but using normal bodies we
could label really the whole mouse
if there's a non-body against a specific
protein you're interested in that works
of course small dice they work well
cell body labeling top rotary api
vascular labels textures they work
perfectly
if it comes to of course specific
labeling with large igg antibodies
there are problems there to be solved
okay thank you ali our next question is
which software
do you use to handle really big data
analyze rendering and video making
thank you
so we have a pipeline that actually
requires multiple softwares currently no
single software solution um
so what we do is scan let's say the
whole mass using blaze
then we stitch everything using arrives
they have a 3d stitching model where you
can
turn around individual blocks and then
we do animations and 3d visualizations
using imarus which still
has a better rendering i might say other
softwares now are catching up
but still they are actually a better one
so this is a bit of like a pipeline i
guess should be
described in detail in general in our
papers
okay thank you so much we have another
question
is there any data for application to
visualizing the skin
is there any application and any data
for
uh i don't understand the question
exactly
um but um so
we did in v disco paper nature neural
science paper we image this
skin intact mouth with the skin where
you can see lymph nodes for example you
can see hair follicles
there are a lot of lymphomas embedded
into skin
so nerve innervations the skin so that a
lot of questions actually can be
answered using we disco technology now
where we can scan a really deep
um throughout the intact skin and
underlying
layers and we actually have this data
scanned
at this um for the we discover paper the
sample so
if the person is asking whether this
data available
we are actually to ship data if someone
is interested in a specific set of data
we can send them if they want to look at
in 3d and analyze for something
okay thank you so much we have another
question
well what are the current limitations of
the technique compared to other
techniques
like eye disco or shift
so we i presented several techniques so
it's hard to just know which one is
being asked for example we use
v-discord technology um for
whole mouse clearing imaging and there
is no such an equivalent technology
that's the only one
if we if we are talking about imaging uh
whole human organs where we use channel
technology and there is no other tech
comparable techniques to anyone
but if we think about application their
application in mass organs
we can compare them individually to
idisco
where for example we we already compared
and reported with v disco technology we
have better
permeabilization and penetration for
normal bodies
and the same with channel comparing
using
chops in human tissue we can
permeabilize
the woman tissue several fold
more than any other clearing
methods that has been available so
we are also now about to
publish a handbook we call it for disco
clearing organic solvents where
people can really have clear ideas of
individual applications
um compared to
uh shift this i don't know if the
twitch may be meant here which is
multiround trailing we don't have any
technology yet for multiround labeling
okay thank you ellie our next question
is
do you have any ideas as to how you
could improve the technology so that you
could
image whole human brains it's a good
point
um well actually it's an exciting point
we are
working on it um so we have to create
the idea actually initially
to shrink the human brain to make it
like a mouse brain
it was a vision but didn't work you know
sometimes you fail and that was one that
we failed
we couldn't find any way to make this
human brain
you know like 1000 times smaller um
but now that means it still shrinks it
becomes maybe half size
we need to scale up the imaging
microscopes have more
we need is more sample holding capacity
larger of that optics with a lot more
working
distance maybe go more infrared
this part we can even see deeper so
these are a few
ways that we are now trying to put
together
but this is really a long-term research
i mean um not
very easy one to tackle but also i think
it's a fair one because as
i just mentioned 12 15 years of brain
mapping there's
no map around i think it would be fair
to try
work on this for a few years
okay thank you we have another question
this may be similar to this question
that you just answered
but i'll ask it anyway how can one image
a human brain with reasonable efforts
so reasonable efforts would be
potentially not image the whole brain
like we to do but
partially you know make it centimeter
slices or take out some regions
hippocampus cortex amygdala you know we
could already image the kidney which is
actually very significantly big
so by imitating the region of interest
which is also not
done so far one could be reasonably
getting some good data
okay we've got some more audience
questions amazing results
apart the very ambitious
application you described 3d organs are
there any diagnostic applications that
can be performed with light sheet
microscopy
yeah so there could be um that's good
one you know exciting application in
general of tissue transparency
technologies
just not to look at nice pictures but
also do
diagnostics for example could be
biopsies could be analyzed
in a much better way now because we
don't have to do
sections and look at tiny pieces of
biopsy but we could do all
biopsy transparent label and look at
all the cells cancer cells and for
better diagnostic
staging of the cancer and maybe better
treatment
options suggesting so this is
actually coming up we are working on
this kind of applications
this is not an electric microscope but
also a lot of
ai it should be involved because when it
becomes large data especially in human
tissue there's a lot of background
and we are working on ai algorithms that
can
overcome and reliably analyze what we
are seeing in this
large human data for diagnostic purposes
okay we have another question um what
are the current
oh never mind i just asked that one um
i'm sorry i got off track
um was there any autofluorescence issue
if yes
how is it resolved so there was a
good auto issue in human
tissue actually a lot um that is
sometimes helpful you can see specific
structures sometimes annoying it's too
much
if you want to do additional antibody
labeling and soon it's hard to decide
what is specific what is not
so we could use copper sulfate
as an agent that reduces
autofluorescence but
in the paper in channel paper we showed
it is
working in small size of tissue
unfortunately we couldn't apply the
whole organ level yet
there are a few methods to reduce the
auto fluorescence
and one could need to test
we are also working partially on it
that's one way but other way could be to
generate props that goes
more far in spectra because
autofluorescence usually comes in green
and red spectra if you go and go
near infrared far red and short
wavelength we will potentially also work
on motor fluorescence
okay our next question is which clearing
method is recommended for doing
multiplex
antibody staining and preserving
endogenously expressed fluorescence
reporter proteins
okay so i could talk about only this
co-line of clearing which we use mainly
because they're really potent in large
tissue
in slices maybe there are some
alternatives but in large tissue they
are i guess at the moment for me at
least
the most reliable multiround labeling
um of the specific antibodies for
mouse organs
i mean we don't actually have a
published protocol i must admit here
there are protocols published
for slices but not for a mouse or gun
yet
and um i cannot really answer this
question because
actually if there is no solution yet for
a mouse organ level false license or
case
one could try this each protocol um
but of course there are some limitations
there and one just has to
check as as usual in many other
technologies
okay we have another question from the
audience let's see
how long does it take in general for
someone to learn the skills necessary
for ai analysis
of analysis of samples specifically for
people with no computer science
background
good so i will answer this question a
bit differently um
there are sometimes people asking in
biology what should i do i'm
bored with this field you know my
risk doesn't just learn how to
program you know machine learning you
need to learn python with
relatively easy to get in and it you
know still
starting now one could become expert of
it in half year one year
then you can find job anywhere as an ai
expert
also in biology of account so in a way
um someone could get all this
you know necessary knowledge background
potentially in a year or so
i would guess to be expert of course
takes always longer
but usually what we do is we i work
i in my group there are six computer
scientists there are computer scientists
with
machine learning background they work on
the projects so for this is the easiest
way
if you want to tackle big problems in a
short time
it's better to work together instead of
just learning it
either learn it do it or just uh
do let it express do it for yourself
or a person gonna do it for you
okay perfect what is the next question
is what is the largest sample that has
been imaged
so the largest sample we meet was the
human kidney
i think about 11 centimeters length um
five centimeters with a four centimeters
take so that's the really the largest
sample ever images elevator fluorescent
microscopy
i'm proud to say so um if you would have
a microscope that is can handle
larger samples we could even image some
larger samples we have
some other organs like lungs and very
transparent and even larger
but they're not meat that there is no
such microscope yet
okay great we have another question
how does deep learning work in your
approaches
so this is not easy to answer i guess in
a short time
so deep learning machine learning deep
learning is a part of machine learning
it learns from or a data that means
there is biologists let's say start
putting labels on the data looking at
the microscopy data says okay
make circles here are the cells as good
as possible then we train the algorithms
saying okay here expert tells
instructors are
cells and then you show different
samples like
so called ground truth and you train the
algorithms and algorithms then
hundreds even thousands of parameters
why did it sell is it size 3d shape
whatever this intensity in 3d space all
these things
adds up and then actually it's like
human being they learn
to judge by themselves what is a better
self after doing a lot of training so it
works like this
again it's really computer science
science
um um
think i would highly recommend to learn
more about it for anyone
this question is about multiple colors
imaging
maximum how many colors can you separate
using your current
setting um we can separate
for five maximum i mean we use four okay
five we didn't really do
three we can easily do i say if you push
it to the four
um this is i think about the limit so
it's not very easy for very large tissue
to split
um a lot of colors so this would be i
guess
so if possible there should be stripping
and re-labeling but we haven't done it
that
organ or mouse level yet
okay we have another question is it
possible to reuse the cleared samples
for other applications like histology or
even molecular analysis of dna
fine so we publish in channel paper you
can
see actually there is the clear kidney
image and then there is the h
is staining afterwards rehydration
sectioning and
looking at the structures with different
labeling technologies antibody one we
published in deep mag paper where we
took out the cancer metastasis from the
cleared mouse
then made it reverse clearing and
antibody labeling so you can do actually
this kind of studies just check the
papers
the channel paper and deep mac paper
okay that's great thank you i have
another question from the audience
can you obtain cellular detail in any
organ tested thus far
um cellular detains so it's um
yes for example the human eye i showed
you individual immune cells
in kidney we didn't label um
actually we have um a top or a tree
labeling individual cells
in gloom like they are clustered
we have trade-off if we want to mix the
whole thing
we have to go a little bit lower
resolution
but then it's like google map after
having an mid-sized view we can
immediately change
the new objective now i guess in blaze
you can do this without
touching the sample then you can zoom in
and get even subcellular
details but to be able to image complete
kidney at cell level at this point i
guess we don't really have a solution
yet
okay looks like i have time for a few
more questions
what else can be done with the vdisco
technology
um so this is i think very exciting
for us in general because a lot of
animal models
diseases are you know modeled on mouse
from neurodegeneration like
a layers you can study peripheral nerve
degeneration
diabetics inflammation cancer metastasis
anything you think would affect the you
know like metabolic disease
could benefit from v disco technology
and then antibody
tracts start as targeting of any disease
small molecules
cartesia all these things could be
potentially
uh benefiting from technology
okay and we have time for one more
question
how can you create human organs based on
the results of human organ mapping
so yeah this is
a wish yet not reality
but there is a vision there um for me
i describe it like this that
imagine you want to make a complicated
skyscraper
what you would need first you don't need
the person who makes the concrete
glass or wires you need the architect
who gave you the plan
then you move to recruiting the people
you need right
exactly like this we need a map of an
organ
to understand how many capillaries per
gallon life or kidney
and all this distance each other the
from small
vessels to large vessels how this
pipeline works
when we understand that we have a
mathematical formula what does it mean
to be a part of a kidney we can
replicate it
otherwise just putting stem cells
ipscs onto dish and expecting them they
will behave like human organs is really
just a wish
as we know now all the organized feels
they are stuck at
um that there is huge heterogeneity but
not
as as well as there is core
that core of the tissue after a few
millimeters
the core is totally that so basically
it is hard to get a large scale human
tissue by random
organization in 3d space so clearly our
organs
they are organized in a specific way
with 3d architecture
if we can replicate this we will be much
closer
to getting something some imitation in
dish that we can use for
human disease modeling human diseases
thank you ali do you have any final
comments for our audience
so um well i mean
experience definitely i would say
it's gonna have a much more impact than
you i guess in general you think
hopefully um because it really provides
an
unbiased view on structure and
potentially more and more to the
molecules
that we can under study diseases now
in a very different way i think this is
very exciting
as i showed in cancer metastasis is
seeing all tiny metastases
and all drug targeting it is it's a
different game now it's not any more
prediction
just by looking at large tumors which
drag is going to work
from prediction we know we move to
knowing
we see every cancer cells and we know
if antibodies drug is working or not i
think this is a
really powerful technology now in cork
applying to different decisions and i'm
very excited
to see how it will really change track
development process
in in the coming years and potentially
help getting much more success in
clinical trials because again
we are moving from pure addiction to
knowing i think this is very exciting
thank you again ellie for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltonia biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's time for replay
if you would like to know how to get
easy access to these fascinating
technologies
please join the webinar from sample prep
to high-res light sheet microscopy
simplify
3d imaging on december 1st and december
3rd
hosted by milton e biotek we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye